- I hear you have a
serious connection with,
like history with American
idol and I didn't know this.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] So, it's with
Jennifer Hudson, right?
- Yeah.
- Wait, tell everyone
this. I didn't know this.
- They asked me to do
American idol and I said,
"You now what I'd like to do?
I'd like to give each of
the people on American Idol
a new arrangement of
the song they picked."
They wanted to do all of my songs.
And I said, "Okay. You can do that."
But I knew everybody
was going to ruin them
if I didn't get my hands on them.
(audience laughs)
So I worked with each
one of them for a week.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I gave them all
different arrangements
the way they wanted it
to. And they were great.
Every one of them was great.
And one of them was Jennifer Hudson.
And she got bumped off that week.
- [Kelly] Oh, the week
that she did your...
- She did a great rendition
of "Weekend in New England".
It was great working with all of them.
- I think it's cool that you let them,
'cause a lot of times they
don't let you be an artist.
You're just singing other people's songs.
I think it's cool that you
let them like, you know,
cater to them, who they are as artists
and like take your song...
- I spent hours with them.
- I know, that's what I'm
saying. That's really kind.
And coming from that world
and living in that world now with boys,
not everybody does that.
So it's really kind.
- I put "I Made It Through
The Rain" on the piano
and then just sing it the
way the piano player played.
And I went, "No, let me help you.
What do you wanna say with 'I
Made It Through The Rain'?"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then little by little,
we would arrange the song for
each artist and it was great.
- I think that's so special.
(audience applauds)
Just taking the time. That's so nice.
Could you talk to Jennifer after that?
- Well, after that, she
got pumped off that week
and I was due to do this
Ryan Seacrest outdoor show.
And I took her with me and I
was supposed to do two songs.
I said, "You do the
second song, Jennifer."
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And I played the piano for her
doing "Weekend in New
England" on Ryan's show.
- That's so nice.
(audience applauds)
- I loved her so much.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Well, she did some things.
- [Barry] Yeah.
- You know how to choose 'em.
You should be an A&R person.